the award to the best supporting actor  of 1950 will be made by last year's best  supporting actress miss Mercedes  McCambridge well the gentleman involved  I know that this moment we seem to last  forever so I'll hurry as fast as I can  the nominees for this year's award is  Best Supporting Actor our Jeff Chandler  in broken out 20th Century Fox Edmund  Gwenn in mr. 880 20th Century Fox Sam  Jaffe in the asphalt jungle  metro-goldwyn-mayer  George Sanders in All About Eve 20th  Century Fox and Erich von Stroheim in  Sunset Boulevard paramount in the began  Sid the winner is George Sanders and all  first nominee quite all the superlative  he is recently been unmasked as a  baritone